citizens of the recheck Nation
so Tara and Andrew they don't really
know each other
they got very different styles
very different Energies
but neither of them have seen the Meg
see how this goes get comfortable you
know be vulnerable have fun drink some
work have fun and that's my part and
I'll see you guys later thank you Tara
why don't you do the intro since you're
here more often okay
and it's me Tara Erickson joined by this
guy I don't know say your name uh my
name I forgot it Andrew Gordon what's
going on Gordon wow all right cool name
Andrew Gordon uh you've never seen the
Meg and mean either so we've bonded over
that at least right yes we're gonna
watch this movie together don't forget
to like comment and also ring the bell
worrying about
when you subscribe were you surprised by
the song and try just did Andrew did you
know that that was my thing I would say
yes but since I watched your last of us
reactions same side we're already we're
already buddies and don't forget guys
when you're on patreon watch along with
sync up just be a patron because then
you can watch the whole thing with me
and him see how we're bonding not
bonding being cool being uncool watching
the make doing some shark stuff uh and I
think that's it do I say more stuff
Andrew no let's watch Jason Statham
versus a shark do it yes
[Music]
thank you
yeah there he is that shark does not
stand a chance
Jason Statham
sew that up buddy headed back to the
rescue vehicle now
I have no idea there's something
[Music]
going with the Alfred Hitchcock approach
of not showing the shark I like it you
okay pal
foreign
oh my goodness this is amazing
uh
wow all right
cold-hearted he's like all of us goners
or just a couple sorry
if we go back everyone dies he's doing
the right thing even though it seems so
mean
yes
Mana one what are you doing come on
bring it in let's go Frain Wilson oh my
goodness with these glasses on I thought
it was Josh Gad I do remember my
daughter our chief marine biologist
[Music]
you know I realize that we're under
construction and everything but I really
think that a world-class Research
Institute deserves a world-class
entrance
sick oh you were eating those words
right now bro this is our Central Hub
which researchers will access all five
flaps
wow look at the humpback whale I love
them this is giving me some deep blue
sea Vibes yeah this is Lucy and her
daughter Gracie
uh oh gosh yeah I was thinking I was
like are they gonna I was like they
don't get mad our engineering sub
designer Jax doc oh John Wick 2 and I
think Batwoman and Orange is the New
Black I think this is our first Ruby
Rose
yes Ruby Rose since 1875 the Mariana
Trench was the deepest place on Earth
what do we think is the bottom but
actually the layer of hydrogen sulfide
if there's warm water below that means
we're going to be the first to see it
and what if you're wrong then you have
wasted 1.3 billion dollars and I will be
fired origin crew we are go for
insertion we are a gopher
insertion
so dumb
it's a movie pre early establishes the
toned yeah right I mean you got just the
idea to see them versus the Megalodon in
general but yeah it is not the bottom
Lori be careful we don't know the depth
on the other side of the sea floor can
come right up on you so the 1.3 billion
was not wasted because they were right
Lorraine Wilson should be doing jumping
jacks yeah I'm like why is he not stoked
you're through well I have multiple
small sonar contacts deploying the
lights
[Music]
jellyfish
free
coffee that's cool
it's like Wally but under the sea this
ecosystem is completely cut off from the
rest of the ocean but the freezing cold
Thermo climb
uh bearing zero eight to zero damn it's
moving fast
all right let's get into it we'll try
and bring up some more lights
no
soon
oh my God
Jonas was right
around his sorrows in the bottle I mean
that's how I would spend my vacay too
now this is shaping up to be an eventful
Tuesday evening you know I like to make
an entrance
make up the five years just showing up
is making an entrance once you're living
above a bar really
that's my dream living above a bar oh
yeah prime time you're gonna offer me
money I'll still say no why don't we sit
down we'll enjoy a couple of beers and
then we can get you on your way it's
like he's watched a bunch of horror
movies
this happened this morning
you didn't say you wouldn't listen to a
voice recording and not do it so here we
go buddy Salon is planned your ex-wife
and a crew are trapped below 11 000
meters possibly dead I have divers with
less experience willing to go but I feel
I owe it to my crew to give this rescue
the best chance of success so we're
going for a ball drunk guy
leave the beer behind and save them
would be kind of entertaining to watch
the shark I bet you he'd be the best one
because he was like loosed up and ready
to go I can probably reboot the
computers
okay try now auxiliary powers back what
are you doing taking notes to my wife
just in case he's a realist
she's very pretty
no all the women in this movie are very
pretty got a candlelights
damn that's tough
having a cheeseburger pen they're really
hot I mean it's interesting they're
really holding on to this oh yeah I only
noticed once you set up
another leaking oxygen we've got a
couple hours
one of the gliders drop the origin and
tore her up if the origins Palace tanks
blow you're gonna die too we have to
okay girl go get him
[Music]
Mama Trudeau
Alex that was a good like heartfelt
moment I like both of those little
actresses they're good
well that thing is awesome yeah all the
stuff with like the underground
submarine type stuff like that's all
really good
oh my gosh I felt like I was like in
that I want that to be a ride I was just
about to say right I'd be so down to do
that oh
as long as there's no no megalodons in
the water oh man but that would make it
fun as long as they just don't like they
can bump us around a little bit like a
fun game of bowling but like you're not
allowed to eat us as long as I know
Jason Statham is somewhere in the water
protecting me I guess that'd be good
okay it's got to be one of the Jason's
either him or Jason Momoa
oh
oh he's in perfect shape just like the
last time you accidentally
he's in perfect shape with all that
alcohol all right he's been drinking 25
beers a day like damn how do I get on
that diet we're in international waters
which means legally I can be the evil
living [__] out of you and get away with
it because I'm Jason Statham
illegally I mean
good thing it doesn't hold a grudge
Cliff Curtis is such a great actor
really believable always really grounded
yeah
oh oh girl what are you doing you must
be the crazy guy no call me there
everyone
um Dr Heller yeah well I'm not crazy I'm
just drunk hey crazy is my mom gonna die
I've kept him bubbles in your mum back
in no time I promise it's kind of star
wars-esque like when they're in the back
of the thing it's like the seat moves
the same oh yeah yeah good point system
go for descent
to go
come on face your fears face your fears
break out a bear you'll get over it
this way you should have brought down
there
come on you gotta go save your ex-wife
buddy I thought he was gonna pull up and
then end credits oh
the end
[Music]
oh man please don't like crash into her
do you know what you're doing buddy
entering thermal climb
oh that has to hurt well and also the
speed he's going yeah it's like probably
should be illegal right because you
should be doing it slow otherwise you
get but the speed I'm gonna have to
divert power from
shut down anything that got us over
he needs a hybridberg chamber
is it still out there I can't
I can't see anything right now
always best way to see if something big
is outside is to put a water cup on the
dashboard
to really block The View oh no you mean
like to see through it gives you like
better I was thinking of Jurassic Park
when the wrecks was oh yeah stomping the
grounds that's how you know something
you're watching you're watching the cup
if it vibrates I got you now I've got
visual other words okay
don't turn on your lights that's bad
fiery magnetic hook three two
see Daisy
[Music]
oh nice save
oh my God yeah they are so strong like
is she gonna just be eaten by a squid
right now
oh shoot your target thing out inside of
his mouth
right I mean you'd waste the turtle oh
good yep that's some Squid Ink so
damn cool
it's so big
yes
it's like 20 25 meters okay that she was
gonna say Fido's like that's way more
than that right but that was a nice Jaws
reference right there cut them off now
15 seconds I have no control
uh-oh oh my goodness
oh okay he's doing flares or something
oh cool smart nice really he's a hero
get out of there your thoughts is clear
I'm headed for the origin now regardless
of what anyone thinks of this movie The
underwater stuff is shot really well
it's awesome yeah
foreign
cool I want one of those I wanted her to
say something like yeah that's probably
my ex we better get out of the way he's
a loose cannon like
with the dialogue so far in this film I
would have expected that one right
she's coming if that thing hits us while
we're still attached
does he have to make the tough decision
again I know right all right you guys
stay down here good luck we'll come back
for you
hurry it up guys come on now
oh gosh oh my gosh he wrote the letter
to his wife oh he just couldn't use it
he knows it oh yeah we should have saw
that foreshadowing
oh he's gonna sacrifice
[Music]
this poor guy
I mean doesn't that also hurt the
Megalodon up in his mouth does that
explosion not harm it at all
to it it's all burnt up it just like
makes him scarier well they actually did
that in Jaws too where the shark got a
little bit burnt up oh and it had like
this really scary scar on the side of
its face
I hope he doesn't blame Jason Statham
again he's like dude this guy sacrificed
himself it's not my fault yeah right
proof is in the pudding in this letter
he was ready you couldn't bring Toshi
back they really they really are blaming
him he saved us
two other witnesses that say no you are
the guy who leaves people behind you go
that deep you take your life in your
hands it's your choice
a fair argument I want to apologize for
before
my temper and you did save my
naked all those muscles
that shark stands no change no chance
look at those abs there's like 17 of
them so
thank you I know it's not easy being the
person who survives you should put on
some clothes yep it's the original plan
okay then carry on oh boy so corny
some of the writing in here I'm like
that's a great singer and some of it I'm
like why would they add that and like
the heartfelt moment she had with her
daughter was great and this is not and
then there's other scenes where it's
like yeah tone is like do we go into a
Nickelodeon channel scene kind of
this is what attacked us damn Megalodon
seven inches 70 and 90 feet
70 and 90 feet largest truck that ever
exists holy junk it feared to nothing oh
my God
hey crazy now that we've actually found
something amazing thank you for keeping
your promise
it's just so sweet it's like literally
the hardest to film so far like I really
feel when she talks I'm like I love her
if you're still selling people back down
there don't call me to come save your
asses Man versus maid is in a fight it's
a Slaughter so man's gonna win
especially if that man is Jason Statham
yeah with his 17 ABS yeah so many I mean
if the shark just saw those abs it would
turn them around like no chance then he
would just scream go tell the other
sharks
is very peaceful but I feel like
something is bad this is science is
building
uh oh my God oh my God oh my oh whoa
spooky
that's gonna be the other alternative
[Music]
so it means it has now crossed the
barrier and is now coming up top because
Dave haven't seen it that high before
yes
curious to see the damage it cost yeah
like where is it is it like leaking oh
do you see the teeth damn that glass is
so strong I mean obviously to withstand
water pressure but yeah Megalodon teeth
[Music]
oh my gosh that legitimately scared me
yeah oh no poor whales oh no humpback go
hide I don't want you to get eat I feel
like let me let me let me in like save
me I don't like it it's sad oh circle of
life just think about the circle of life
it was one degree Celsius right yeah but
a minute later when the evolution came
up the temperature increased by 25
degrees a shark could come right through
there oh because there was those weird
seismic things they were down there yeah
these sharks have no fins they were
killed by shark poachers it's disgusting
that people do that why do they do that
I hate those people they should be put
to death normally I don't want the shark
to this Meg to eat people but in this
case it'll make an exception those
people eat them all like I'm glad I hope
the Meg did eat them all if we can shoot
the mag in a soft spot like his mouth or
gills we can inject it with something
lethal it's gonna take at least 20
minutes to rig the cage nothing will be
gone at two the cage you have a cage
that big there's no way safest way to
approach is without a vehicle hold up
one of us alone in the water is no
okay who the hell is gonna make that
swim
I can't swim it's okay you just sit
there and save your money if I get eaten
you don't feel really bad
all right he's insane to jump in the
water but he Statham he can do it that's
true he's got 17 ABS he's good
oh my goodness oh my God I can't believe
he's just like just the fins always get
me like
oh boy it's going under
[Music]
why didn't you bring goggles sir uh that
might have been a good idea yeah
oh there you go good okay you're Tara
thank goodness okay I'm listening it
would literally if that was me there
would be a lot of brown
laughs
take it back bring me back yeah yeah
shoot it and then I guess run
run in water why do a water run
oh got it
right right can they really like really
that's not gonna be good for the shark
to see you better keep your body
straight as [__]
oh no vibration
screw that get the vibration
oh [__]
did they say how fast it can go the
shark no but like we saw it oh
wow that's insane
oh man I will get you in here and your
17 ABS yes this is awesome
oh he's out of there oh is he
underground like forget about it
oh my God holy junk that was crazy okay
same time tomorrow be a son of a [__]
but you sure as hell no cow good job you
got guts yeah but just because he's not
a coward doesn't mean he's not dumb yeah
but I guess I can't call him dumb
because he succeeded so he did he did
his job and I feel like him and what is
her name I forgot it already
a little bit of love connect right then
when he was back home I thought the
foreshadowing was when he was connecting
with her daughter and like is this going
to be a surrogate father totally remind
me again was a good idea
what it's a shark cage
plastic showcase I'd want mine to be
like 10 000 times bigger than that
before I get in the water that's too
small polycarbonate specifically
designed not to crack maybe talking
about breaking that's eight to nine
hundred thousand I don't like it doesn't
like it I wouldn't get in there exactly
I'm with him I'm not getting in there
either either of us I know about this
can penetrate the Megalodon skin let me
go don't worry about me let me do what I
do best I kind of wish she spoke in
Chinese more in this because when she
does she's talking to her daughter in
Chinese right yes and I really believe I
was like with it more like I know but
then he couldn't understand her
she stays them he probably speaks every
language I know right like maybe he's
just a guy who's like I know a little
bit and then they have conversations I
think that would have been cool that
would have been a nice connection too
yeah yeah right
so you you know tastes good
thank you bye-bye good luck I'm glad
he's in a joking mood after his friend
was just annihilated totally he was so
serious at the meeting table now he's
just like oh this is no big deal so yeah
just another's day work yeah
they're like yeah heck yeah give me this
food you all better get out of there
oh yeah they sense the big one coming
they're like we're out
good luck lady come on come on come on
it's on its way 50 meters 50 meters
I figure it would be visible by now
right like it's funny how they're like
always looking around and then all of a
sudden
that's not that's fighting dirty sir
oh my God whoa that thing is gnarly it
also looks really old and like wrinkly
look he's got like wrinkles
amazing is that foreshadowing in the eye
just saying I don't know
oh he's coming back angry
oh it's gonna pull that puppy off the
chain yeah
they didn't really think this plan
really didn't you better cut that cord
you're gonna have to let her go
otherwise it's gonna take down the boat
oh
good girl where'd she where'd she hit
him I think she hit him in his like get
gills oh that didn't do much
that cage will not break that's the
problem the cake is being swallowed oh
you guys didn't think about that part
oh yep he's just gonna oh God
did you hear rain Wilson he said hell
yeah he's like speaking for the audience
I love it I love that
wait is he ever a tank down there do you
just go without it I think he went
without it right yeah I think he just
went with like a god like a goggle thing
yeah I don't know I didn't see
[Music]
uh-oh okay good enough distraction oh
wait he he does have the the tank on oh
he does okay okay
my mouth gets broken oh no I'm losing
air
okay well it's all right 17 I'm Gonna
Save you oh no somebody help her hello
yeah are you how are you guys not
looking around for the woman who fell
out of the boat
okay she's maybe not dead ah hurry hurry
come on Jackson
oh my goodness no Jonas go get back to
the ship
is he gonna give her his oxygen tank
kind of like Star-Lord did for Gamora in
space probably because he could probably
free dive too like once he has enough
air he'll probably we're gonna set a
track guys I need some bait
oh God it's right there oh good he's
going for the bait
come on
why would you be holding on to the chain
I also would not be anywhere near the
edge right like be in the middle of the
boat come on guys whoa that's spooky oh
oh my goodness
oh did the thing finally kick in is it
dead no like the stuff she gave him
finally kicked in maybe the meds
come on now
let Statham do it oh right that guy's a
doctor well like he'll do that I forgot
yeah Jason do the bear part yeah I'm
sure that's how she would prefer it
anyways yeah right because something you
might want to see
what they call they caught what it what
oh okay so they did Kill the shark oh my
goodness
that's why I thought it was that but you
want a proper picture get your head
inside no way that little amount was
like lethal come on get in okay I
thought we're making jokes right now
[Applause]
oh my God I would not put my head
anywhere near that thing oh also where
is this prop I need to go see it
next to the mic
oh was it different is he saying they're
different or smaller what I'm thinking
we did what people always do
discover
and then destroy what are you supposed
to do to leave this thing alive I mean
come on he was gonna kill him I agree
with what he's saying about it but not
in this case come on also you have a
huge like living fossil it also belongs
in a museum yeah
oh my god oh he just jumped on the boat
tamale y'all thought you caught and
destroyed that puppy still living damn
well that was like the first Jaws they
remember they caught that shark and
thought it was it was the tiger shark
yeah the real woman was out there still
whoa and obviously the shark jumping
onto the boat like Jaws yes
yeah a lot of like references right
everything I mean that's the point
that's the goat of course you're gonna
reference that movie oh my God tip the
whole boat over whoa
what get out of here
in the middle of the ocean yeah
destroying 75-foot megalodons wasn't
no I don't know
you're dead still has to be alive right
yeah see them just saving everybody he
really is I'm Queen
that line reminds me of the line at the
end of Deep Blue Sea where Thomas Jane
goes man I tell you I quit this job yeah
I
the other line of with that he said like
this isn't part of the job description
this wasn't part of the job is like from
one of I don't know I can't think of the
movie it's like one of those like
Classics I do remember that line I just
don't remember I'm sure I'm sure the
lovely people will let us know in the
comments but I do remember that line I'm
just oh that's gonna kill me now what
yeah you're gonna be okay
wait what the doctor's gonna go go is he
gonna sacrifice himself oh yeah
okay but you're the doctor you could
save people and they got hurt but all
right buddy
one easy gulp
I wonder if he's still swimming around
in there because that thing is oh oh my
God was that two that was a major blood
trail I don't think he's still swimming
in there Orpheus it's in pieces no I
mean like swimming in his stomach like
it is like his mouth and his like
I don't think that's that's jet engine
is not
probably Good Vibration right oh
maybe it's okay okay better to be on
that than the sinking boat but sure not
not feel good in that thing either yeah
good news guys it's payback time whoa
they're gonna try and shoot it
[Music]
sure jump up for the helicopter it's
gonna like why haven't you already
started shooting at it but what are you
what are they doing oh in Jaws 2 the
shark actually did eat a helicopter oh
dope
pretty hysterical actually oh you're
just gonna make him mad another tracker
we already know where it's at well I
think we have that you're gonna blow it
up I was gonna say I think the tracker
also was on the other one that got
killed right oh you're right
too much water got in his lungs is that
what happened I don't know I mean maybe
that was a great little scene yeah
that's right I like it when the movie is
being more serious yeah I mean I know
it's it a Megalodon shark it works yeah
but but like it doesn't have to be you
know the other part of the tone of the
movie is like we could still be there
just not as corny mixed with like that
moment I really felt yeah not as corny
and not as much like tone it down a
little bit Yeah like like a good 30 and
then we're in believable land yeah yeah
I love my two best friends to die
you know just about the ones you lose
it's also about
the ones you save definitely saved a lot
more than he's lost yeah but they act
like it's the opposite yeah a lot of
times
I thought that was a good scene rounded
believable like good emotion Chinese are
sending two destroyers to take it out
and an evacuation ship is coming here
tomorrow morning I came here to
celebrate with you
and now I'm mourning with you another
good sense it's funny it's like it's
like the the like we said like the
emotional scenes that are like grounded
and really realistic like it actually
hit yeah
told me about you and suyen
can I believe how about you just
just try something
[Music]
product placement yeah
Coca-Cola we are not getting within a
mile of that monster until the
helicopter kills it why is rain Wilson
even going out here yeah I'm like you're
the billionaire you're home hire the
teams but watch it on a video camera or
something that's what I mean like for
him I'm like shouldn't you be home
I hope like oh he just like wanted to
see it
we got him oh no you didn't you barely
broke the skin hit it again
well that's already that's the
yeah what is that
oh
jump down there give me a couple of
teeth big ones from my desk oh my God it
looked like a squid it looked like a
squid I could be wrong
easy oh
oh sharks are eating it yeah and they're
not cannibals like would sharks eat
another dead shark oh well Megalodon oh
damn that's yeah that's part of me
thing doesn't have any teeth
we kill the whale that's what I was
saying it was a whale or a squid yeah
yeah bye bye billionaire
good luck
yeah
that's right it's fine he's gonna eat
you and the squid at the same time buddy
that will not save you
that's awesome oh he didn't get oh what
oh he just went through the uh
laughs
wow whoa I think his hand was still
alive yeah
didn't call anyone no one knows the
Sharks out there oh oh wow the hell was
he thinking he wanted to make this go
away as quietly as possible oh yeah
investors that's yeah makes sense we're
really gonna do this a lot of people are
gonna die if we don't make how do you
feel about coming during that Evac ship
well I'd say uh
it's a great day to go fishing
20 minutes can you get there first
doubtful yeah we're gonna have to
getting there first one mean anything if
we don't have a plan
maybe we have a plan just Jason say them
yeah swim in the water and kill this
thing how are we gonna get it here when
there's a beach full of people to eat
right here
you ask it out for dinner
oh so they play the sound from the boat
oh my God that is a lot of people and
they're really deep in the water too
tamale I have never seen an ocean look
like that where there's that many people
actually in the ocean no not the dog no
not you do not show a dog getting eaten
I will be so upset no get the dog out of
the water oh my God it's eat literally
any person do not eat the dog seriously
if you do that I'm I'm just oh no I
can't no there's a little puppy dog
oh my God somebody grabbed the dog
hey that dog is out now just swimming
why is no one like fervently swimming
behind it to try to get the dog oh my
God
swim and chill no no no no no no no no
no no don't get the puppy dog no no no
did it I don't like it
okay
I hope this isn't an ALICE kittner
situation like in Jaws one remember the
kid who won the yellow raft yes I said
Mom just 10 more minutes oh my god oh
is the dog still alive that's what we
want I don't care about any of these
people except maybe the kid I want him
to live yeah yeah I mean the kids any
kids but that that one he's very cute
oh that's not good whoa yeah he's gonna
eat that ball that's gonna be fun for
him to play with bounce that around Mega
[__]
oh my gosh this ocean is there is a lot
going on a lot of targets for the shark
yeah
I really do love all those POV shots
yeah yeah it's cool oh no the tracker
sayonara trackie damn it
that's not good nope
oh but is it dragon and anchor now
oh no
um
time to get off that thing yeah
oh gosh it's got both of them now
oh okay yeah
that was a funny delivery of the lineup
sometimes I think it's some of the
direction in this movie that maybe the
people would normally like deliver
certain things that way but maybe
they're being directed a certain way
right
oh my God
you could literally just swallow like 50
people yeah
there we go see you later oh
oh yep
she's cut in half
whoa
oh
my God the kid
oh my goodness oh yay the sound
if I was one of those people who were
fortunate enough yeah I would never ever
go to the ocean ever again yeah it's
swimming pools for me the rest of my
life yeah yeah if that even that water
is probably gonna traumatize me because
I'm just gonna think about that shark
yeah look up
oh he's just gonna eat it like that
what's wrong join us come make the shot
it's too close to the ship
oh my God
Jonas what's going on down there try to
stay out of its mouth
that's a good idea
oh he's gonna oh cool
oh he could just hide here
uh
oh no dang always gotta add now some
kind of an obstacle in this movie yeah
nice yeah
[Music]
can't see the shock but something's
going on up here
I think this is a moment where you get
your shot there's a lot of helicopters
present here we come
bastard
oh my goodness
at least it's working again yeah yeah
damn he had a clear shot too gosh
[Music]
uh what you guys need to watch where
you're driving
oh
[Music]
and this was not even the Megalodon's
fault this is because you dum-dums
weren't looking where you were going I
mean guys who are with the cameras look
at the shark and the guy flying pay
attention in the air like what this was
not a well thought out plan okay I'm
leading it away from the ship
get the little girl out of the water
yeah come on now
jacket on a life jacket oh look at her
she's helping him I love how she's
calming him down
no don't worry about the bus I got you
I got you
she she might be my favorite character
she might be my favorite character mine
hands down
she's beautifully written and performed
yeah like her little character Arc and
how strong she is and like is perfect
are you gonna kill it evolution
I'm gonna make this thing bleed
see and we said before you were right
it's not about the people you lose it's
about the ones you save
that's about the bippy is safe oh he's
gonna sacrifice himself like was he
gonna fly into his mouth and turn off
the flares there's flares right that's
what I would do fly into his mouth set
off all the flares nothing like playing
chicken with a Megalodon right
[Music]
that's much cooler than what I thought
that was sick how had nobody thought of
that before that was awesome
[Music]
it's got to be bleeding to death yeah I
mean he got a good chunk
oh
my that shot is insane
oh the eyes I yeah he's gonna stab it
right in its eye yeah because remember
he pointed the laser at it earlier
[Applause]
oh
awesome I know when sharks attack they
always close their eyes to protect their
eyes but the reason I said earlier is
this possible foreshan because he was
pulling the laser and the shark was like
blinking its eyes
oh oh they're all attacking it now
because it's mortally wounded
that's a lot of sharks oh my goodness
Glock 17 abs they don't care about him
they're going for the the main meat yeah
get her oh my god oh but don't eat
somebody's gonna eat the explosion thing
oh
my turn to save you yeah
[Music]
oh that is uh look at him swimming out
of its mouth that's crazy that is food
for weeks yeah months
foreign
[Applause]
get the doggy I've never been so happy
in my life thank goodness at least the
writers had enough common sense of
decency that dog better be living I like
that the Callback was much later he's
just still swimming
nothing like a shark bringing people and
families together right from Megalodon
to Mega family
yay
yay clits onto Mega family love it
that's going to be the next title the
new movie
oh oh I was like I I got nervous there
is it the end where's the Royal credits
okay did it say Finn the way it's Finn
like Finn means the end but it's in not
in the language that any of it was
spoken in right isn't Finn like I'm in
shark fin right I mean oh right uh I
don't know there you go I was like isn't
that French
or like Le Finn whatever it is
um
oh my God
oh boy
oh right I should pause this yeah
or we can just turn the volume down I
think
this yeah the orange one
oh my God that was so much fun it was
fun I mean it was corny and cheesy as
hell but I mean the whole idea of Jason
Statham versus a megalodon you're gonna
get cheesy and corny as hell but I will
say for his cheesing corny as it was I
really did appreciate like the few
scenes where there was drama and um of
course tension stuff like that but those
scenes with uh shoes
Yen her father and her daughter like I
mean when they were like grounded in
reality and just having like dramatic
moments like I actually really enjoyed
those things I know everyone's like but
the shark scenes were your favorite
right right they were entertaining but
like those are the scenes like that I
was relating to the most and the scenes
like I was invested in the most the rest
was just bombastic ridiculous fun
entertaining stuff but like in terms of
serious stuff I enjoyed the most
I know I don't know why I'm picking that
but it was in my opinion it was the best
and uh that I enjoyed the most of it oh
yeah I mean I enjoyed the shark stuff a
lot like I mean I was screaming yelling
the entire time because I think it looks
so awesome but I agree I'm like oh if
this film had more of that emotionality
and those characters who are very
grounded I really liked it when they
spoke and they're like native language I
really like I don't know I just really
liked her performance a lot more
um but uh I think if they could have
found a way to add that seriousness into
the whole script and sure you can have
jokes but not lay it on so thick like
make it more like just technical we're
down here even from the beginning it was
already like insertion and it was like
oh are we really doing aren't we isn't
that like old new old news I was gonna
say old News Bears
um I just felt like it was old kind of
jokes that they were using that is like
that's such an easy go-to like what
writer in the room wasn't like maybe
should make that better but also how is
this gonna play overall to these great
scenes that we have that add emotion and
depth to it but but mixed with I know
you want comedy because then it makes it
fun but like
I didn't it wasn't as grounded yeah I
might get I mean this is I'm just making
a hyperbole in uh guess here but my
guess is they're like look this whole
idea of this movie is ridiculous in
general so we're just gonna have fun uh
just throw a lot of light-hearted jokes
in here and stuff like that but to your
point I just think if they would about I
think the key word is balanced yeah you
could have balanced the tone a little
more I would have taken this and I know
again the whole idea of Jason Statham
versus a 75-foot shark is just again on
its face like that's ridiculous but
right still like I could have if you
would have had more scenes like that
with in terms of tone with some
light-heartedness of course you can have
jokes like I'm not saying don't put
humor in the film right I just think
that would have gone a long way because
a lot of times too and again I'm not a
writer I don't claim to be one I have
massive respect for writers I know it's
a very difficult job I have attempted to
do it it's not easy yeah um but a lot of
this it wasn't even the it's just a lot
of the lines I'm like you guys are
trying to be way too smart for you I'm
good I'm like just calm down calm down
here a little bit but it was like if you
do it once or twice it's like okay
whatever but when you're constantly
doing it and it's not you can try and be
smarter than you think if you're
executing it properly but if it's not
executed properly it now it becomes a
little Annoying that's what I was gonna
say that it might be the direction too
because if a lot of those lines were
more thrown away yeah even from the
beginning like insertion and nobody paid
attention to it and was just like you're
going with that again Sam great uh
insertion but it was delivered a
different way rather than uh kind of put
on like put on like we're saying a joke
and we're gonna show her saying a joke
and that didn't happen a lot that was
only a couple instances that I was like
that seems corny but there was some in
here where I legitimately laughed via
the delivery that was just very off the
cuff and I thought it was great
um I thought uh I thought a lot of
people in here were like were really
good but I specifically really like Sue
yin and her daughter a ton like their
performances when they spoke again like
I said no more native language or just
their relationship up I I love them the
little girl is like my favorite oh man
that's great she's the best I mean
acting in general is of course very
difficult but I mean yeah especially
when child actors can do a great job
it's even more like damn like because he
got a whole production of people working
it's it's already a tough enough job as
is so it's just you know I always give
you know to my my cap to children who
can do a really like great job and she
was fantastic and I mean to me that was
the Crux of the whole heart of the film
was I mean obviously Statham was a star
he was he was very entertaining in the
film but the relationship between them
like that got me so invested and to the
point where obviously I didn't want
anything to happen to either of them
right um and obviously I did even though
I didn't know too much about the dad
just because I was so invested in the
daughter and her mother I was I still
was saddened by the father uh the
grandpa um uh losing his life scene with
them that's sad and but I've changed my
mind she's she's my second favorite
character the
is not afraid to swim in the middle of
the ocean yeah that takes guts like I
wouldn't even swim in the middle of the
ocean so that's that's one Brave dog but
again for all the faults we we say of
the writers I'm glad they kept Pippin
alive at least yes and that little boy
in his popsicle survived yeah oh my gosh
a popsicle was still it just in such
good form after all that drama
um I I mean I had a lot of fun I loved
it when they have that big shark on
there that we think is the Megalodon the
Megalodon actually shows up yeah oh that
was fun oh I think my favorite shot was
the Megalodon coming out of the water
after Jason had stuck it in its eye and
you actually saw like the depth of field
of how like large he was outside of the
water with Jason next to him I loved
that so much into the film's crit I
thought like visually a lot of the
underwater stuff and the cinematography
under the water and also too
the technical the technological advances
we saw in like the the submarine stuff I
mean I thought that was all really well
done like I was like I want to go I mean
I'm not even an underwater program like
you want to go on assuming there's no
megalodons out there I want to go on
this side like this looks great this is
so this is a great way to explore like
the use of the budget in terms of what
they were doing underwater I thought it
was all great and even the stuff with
the shark I mean I I thought visually
like it looked great and I love the
approach they they did at the beginning
with the Alf Alfred uh hitchcockian uh
and Steven Spielberg Jaws where you're
not really seeing the shark it's just
not using it not yeah you're using your
mind to imagine what what the shark is
doing even though we can see things that
are happening to things underwater but
you kind of got to use your mind and I
love I love when they do stuff like that
in shark films yeah like the teeth
imprint with the little girl was awesome
oh that was crazy and now I'm still like
was that the actual megalodon or was it
the smaller one it wasn't the smaller
one because then that would that's when
they were like it's not the same teeth
marks right exactly that's what that's
where I mean because that's one I mean
also too the fact I was like I feel like
this is too soon and too anti-climactic
for this to just be the end already over
but yeah that's because they saw those
bite marks that's where they were able
to uh where Jason Statham was able to
say no the bite marks were definitely
bigger than the teeth we're seeing here
yeah and then also too I believe that
was a callback in reference as well to
uh Richard Dreyfus in Jaws playing Matt
Hooper where he was taking uh
measurements of the tiger shark and
saying that that's not the bite marks on
this are different than the bite radius
on uh Chrissy Watkins the victim of the
the first victim of in the Jaws yeah
yeah different teeth man I'd love to
hold the call I mean there was I'm sure
there were plenty I missed but I loved a
lot of the callbacks and references to
jaws and I'm sure there were other shark
films that were being referenced but
obviously clearly Josh was yeah a major
influence on this film which it should
be of course yeah not only the greatest
Shark film of all time it's one of the
greatest films of all time in my opinion
yeah yeah
I agree I mean any last thoughts I mean
I had a lot of fun I'm I want to see
number two doesn't number two come out
soon yeah I believe very soon like this
week or something yeah something like
that I mean I definitely want to see but
let us know in the comments yeah do you
want Tara and I to see it in theaters or
would you prefer we wait digitally and
see it here with you guys good question
Andrew he needs to know I need to know
uh you guys can find me at Tara Erickson
all over the Internet Instagram all this
stuff what about you Igor 7-Eleven oh
that's cool do you hit 7-Eleven a lot
it's my birthday I knew it but I wanted
him to go yep big gulp in it
that's not where you get your C4 no
Amazon Amazon that's where you buy
everything I feel like yeah nobody goes
to the store and they're even closing
down Bed Bath and Beyond now all of them
are shutting down like what is this yeah
it's fully all right the world that we
live in is is done yeah everything's
online nowadays and it wasn't taken over
by Megalodon it was taken over by
not really but kind of
yeah yeah right
well that's it guys leave a like leave a
comment you know what to do also uh hold
on they're gonna have to cut this out
but I think I have to say something
about patrons what do they say at the
end or are they just like Buy
to forget it's been a while since I've
been on so I don't remember the patreon
don't forget if you're not already
Patron you should become a patron
because then you can sit with me and
Andrew watch the whole thing it's it's a
blast of Rooney we'll be back you guys
tell us what you like what you don't
like what should we watch again we love
sharks and we love you that's it bye
foreign